By 10-year-old daughter has been diagnosed by ultrasound testing with radodes in her toes.
She doesn't seem to have it anywhere else.
It's probably been years that she has had it, but symptoms started to flare more recently,
turned a red purple, color, and sore.
It seems like it obviously is a blood flow problem.
It is year-round symptoms, not just what it's cold, but winter is a little worse.
Besides keeping it warm and foot massages, what suggestions do you have that you could
look into as far as the why she has this and what you could do about it?
Well, I don't, radodes has similar properties to, it's definitely a reactive condition.
You need to react to different things.
A lot of people will have radodes in cold weather.
This person says it doesn't make a difference.
Some are winter, same thing, hot cold doesn't make any difference.
So you have to look for triggers.
So similar to an autoimmune disease where you're looking for possible triggers.
So the constriction of the blood vessel has to do with a sudden down-regulation of the
H2 receptor and its connection to nitric oxide with radodes, similar type things with blood
pressure issues with patients with high blood pressure where they have a down-regulation
of the H2 receptors, many times blockage of those and a decrease of nitric oxide, many times
with blood pressure issues and cardiac issues it has to do with either lime, heavy metal,
Hpilori, much more common than it has to do with arterial constriction due to like cholesterol.
But you can't have actually the arteries for that, but with radodes, it has to do with
a reactive constriction at the smooth muscle layer underneath the endothelial layer of the
vessels.
So you have to look for triggers.
So with radodes, it's be the same investigation that you do if you have an autoimmune disease,
you're looking for what could be the possible trigger that is setting off by flares.
So same thing radodes, you're having a flare, what's setting off that flare?
Could be a food, could be a toxin, could be some sort of pathogen.
So typically a trigger that sets off a flare in an autoimmune disease or any of these immune
responses like asthma, which is also an immune response.
You have to look for the triggers.
The triggers could be food related.
So doing a food profile would be a good thing looking at that person's gut health is really
important.
It could be pathogen related, a person could have a latent viral infection that is a chronic
viral infection that many times you can't get rid of a virus out of your body.
They can live in it or ganglion and they come out in opportunistic times.
Could be antibodies to different other pathogens like bacteria and things like that.
You could also have antibodies to different chemicals.
So every time you're exposed to that chemical, now you fire this immune reaction and you
get this reaction.
So looking for those triggers, sometimes it's daunting, like I can't figure out what
set this off.
I would start with diet.
I would start with the gut because many times even if the gut and the diet is the trigger
once you clean that up, it's kind of like you're emptying out the bucket, you're cleaning
up the body and you're not going to be as reactive to other things that you may have
antibodies against.
So cleaning up the diet, cleaning up the gut, healing the gut, and it'll many functional
medicine doctors start with that, and I wouldn't say it's necessarily the cause of everything.
But certainly, if you do clean that up, it can decrease your reaction to so many other things.
So it's a wise place to start.